welcome to Hannity and tonight two
massive beams of light they are shining
into the sky above New York City a
solemn reminder of the deadliest terror
attack on American soil or
2977 innocent men women children were
murdered on September the 11th 2001
including hundreds of heroic First
Responders who are running up the stairs
of the World Trade Center as the Twin
Towers were about to collapse why
because they wanted to save lives they
are the very personification the
definition of heroic in every way and
courageous we'll never forget we won't
forget the Brave New York City
Firefighters the police officers the
paradise paramedics and others we won't
forget the heroes on flight 93 let's
roll we won't forget those who are still
dying to this day from breathing toxic
air during the rescue and Recovery
efforts unfortunately Joe Biden is not
in New York City tonight or at the
Pentagon in Arlington Virginia yeah or
in Shanksville Pennsylvania he's the
first U.S president in 22 years not to
visit an attack site on the anniversary
of 9 11. he commemorated the attacks in
Vietnam of all places before making a
quick stop in Alaska to visit U.S
soldiers on his way back to the U.S
during a short speech on the tarmac
Biden opened with one of his usual
stupid jokes and later suggested that
so-called political extremism in America
is a bigger threat than Al Qaeda and
then to top it off per usual if I didn't
turn the conversation act to himself his
favorite topic with yet another lie
about visiting Ground Zero in New York
City the day after 9 11. here's a
spoiler alert Joe Biden was nowhere near
New York City the day after 9 11. take a
look
Brown zero New York
and I remember standing there the next
day and looking at the building I felt
like I was looking through the gates of
hell it looked so devastated because the
way you could away from where you could
stand
Joe Biden was lying again 22 years later
and Joe Biden doesn't seem to remember
what really happened on that horrific
day no one in this Administration seems
to understand the gravity of the 9 11
Terror attacks remember the 911
Commission report they were at war with
us we were not at war with them what
about the seven to eight million illegal
immigrants Joe is not vetted coming into
this country uh by the way we caught
many people on the terrorist watch list
how many on that list got through as
gotaways we have no clue no idea you
know who thought it was a good idea to
plan a trip to Vietnam on 9 11 anyway
and who thought this tweet was a good
idea Biden's National Security Council
spokesperson on 9 11 praising Saudi
Arabia for their commitment to
infrastructure quote we welcome this
weekend's Announcement by Saudi Arabia
committing 20 billion to support
President Biden's signature initiative
the partnership for Global
infrastructure picture now keep in mind
this is the same Biden Administration
that tried to cut a plea deal with the
Saudi linked terrorists who planned 9 11
in order to spare their lives the Al
Qaeda five as we call them including the
Mastermind Khalid Sheikh Mohammed and
the same Administration that just freed
up six billion dollars for the number
one state sponsor of Terror in the world
Iran uh evading all U.S sanctions by
passing the money through South Korea
and then Qatar and exchange Iran has
agreed to release six American hostages
sounds like Joe paid a ransom to me this
has got to be the biggest Ransom payment
as a matter of fact in the history of
the world six billion dollars to the
number one state-sponsored terrorism on
the anniversary of 9 11. boy that's just
brilliant and I don't know who's making
these psychotic decisions at Joe's white
house but the President Joe doesn't seem
to have a firm grip on anything just
look at this press conference it was an
utter complete disaster in Vietnam take
a look
you know there's that one of my staff
members said Remember the famous song
You Know Good morning Vietnam well good
evening Vietnam my brother loves having
there's famous lines some movies that he
always quotes you know is it and one of
them is there's there's a movie about
John Wayne he's an Indian scout scout
Indian looks at John Wayne and points to
the union so says he's a lion dog face
pony soldier
well there's a lot of lion dog face Pony
soldiers out there about about global
warming I'm just following my orders
here
uh
staff is there anybody having spoken but
I tell you what I don't know about you
but I'm going to go to bed
yeah we thought we talked about we
talked about at the conference overall
we talked about stability we talked
about making sure that the third world
the excuse me third world the uh the the
uh the southern hemisphere had access to
change it had access it wasn't
confrontational at all thank you
everybody descends account press
conference thanks everyone
thank you
[Music]
no wonder China Russia Iran and North
Korea are now aligning that's the leader
of the Free World weird bizarre mumbling
bumbling stumbling rambling stories
about Here We Go Again The Lying dog
face pony soldier pre-selected questions
the mental fog around simple tasks and
then a staffer at the end literally
interrupting him you know play the music
cue the music you know to avoid even
more embarrassment after a 26-minute
disaster Joe Biden is not leading
anything he's barely hanging on for dear
life now earlier in the trip more Biden
signature lies as well look at this
and when will you
Mr G well I hope I get to see Mr Shea
sooner than later I've spent more time
in the million other world leader have
some total over the last 12 years so I
hope you get to see him again soon
Joe Biden frequently claims he traveled
17 000 miles with China's dictator
president XI a lie that was rewarded
with three pinocchios even from the far
left Washington Post now of course Biden
does have deep Family Ties to China well
connected Chinese Nationals reportedly
supplying the bidens with millions of
dollars diamonds at least one lavish
shopping spree uh you know tons of money
and business with in energy with cefc
the the Chinese government's oil giant
uh then of course the 1.5 billion dollar
deal Bank of China I wonder why how many
millions did the Biden family Syndicate
how much did they do in business with
China how much of that money was profit
how much did the grandchildren get how
much did Hunter get how much did Joe get
is this really the best the Democratic
party can do in 2024 you have what is a
heartless self-centered corrupt career
politician one foot in a nursing home
and by the way way since Biden had a big
trip this weekend don't expect to see
much of him in the coming days he'll be
sleeping that off he needs ample time to
recharge the battery probably needs
another three weeks vacation just too
weak to handle the rigors of the job hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else